c'est le dernier pierre bédier hervé est
élu président du conseil départemental
des hybrides sans surprise pierre bédier
garde son fauteuil de président réélu
avec 100% des voix du conseil dans son
discours l'élu du canton de
mantes-la-jolie a mis en avant un
département qui protège c'est notre
compétence première dans la compétence
sociale et en particulier le rsa à la
fois la distribution du rsa c'est donc
le département qui financent et qui
finance
au grand dam de ses propres finances
puisque l'état qui devrait en théorie
nous rembourser en totalité ne le fait
que aux deux tiers autres quarts et nous
avons aussi à côté du rsa la politique
d'insertion 12 vice-présidents ont aussi
été élus lors de cette séance
pierrefonds reste premier vice président
marie hélène aubert catherine arnould ou
encore joséphine coleman ce berger sont
aussi présentes
la mère de plaisir avec nicolas
dainville sont les seuls représentants
de saint quentin en yvelines
six ans ça passe très très vite on a
énormément travaillé avec mes collègues
dans tous les secteurs et on a toujours
la sensation qu'il ya des dossiers qui
sont en cours qu'il faut terminer donc
je remercie le président de sa confiance
et de cette vice-présidence que je vais
porter vraiment avec énergie des
nouveaux élus et nouveau vice président
âgé de seulement 26 ans geoffroy backs
de keating et élus 11e richarde le
pierre mehr modem du chéné rocancourt
est 5e
c'est évidemment un grand honneur mais
c'est voilà après si on est
je suis très satisfait parce que ça va
être un engagement c'est vraiment
derrière beaucoup d'actions qui vont
être engagées au sein du département
donc j'arrive directement par la grande
porte et donc très satisfait et
après il ya peu d'appréhension
évidemment c'est la finalisation d'un
accord politique
le président avait souhaité élargir sa
majorité départementale le modem à voile
a signé un accord avec avec le président
et les résultats du scrutin nous en
ayons été favorable le président a tenu
ses engagements et je l'en remercie
si les délégations seront officiellement
attribués lors de la prochaine séance du
conseil départemental celle de la santé
devrait être attribué à laurent richard
richarde le pierre obtiendrait les
mobilités geoffroy backs de keating
serez aux affaires sociales
nicole bristol aurez en charge
l'environnement